the singular ambition of this summit to
demonstrate that the world's wealthy
liberal democracies can work
together the g7 a force for good
in a world beset by problems and this
man would love to be the one who unites
them
i know that the world was looking to us
to reject some of the selfishness and
nationalistic approaches that have
marred the initial
global response to the pandemic noble
aims but a nationalistic issue the
a bit of a sour taste in the mouth at
this summit hasn't it
instead of building global alliances
you're moving further apart from allies
and
you seem to have provoked a diplomatic
row now too with france
do you regret blowing up the brexit row
and some of your remarks
the vast vast majority of the
conversations
uh that we've had over the last three or
four days have been
about other subjects and there has been
a fantastic degree of harmony i mean
between the leaders of the uh of our of
our countries and and if you look at
some of the things
they come together uh to uh to a greener
billion
more doses uh a new atlantic charter
uh a plan to build back better for the
world that was what took up
our our time and um you know
i i don't think that uh really i could
have asked for
a more cooperative or or a more
energetic spirit from
uh from our friends foreign secretary
said this morning on television
that he found president macron's remarks
on gb and ni offensive are you telling
me that's not a diplomatic route
i i what i'm saying is that uh
we will do uh whatever it takes to
protect the
territorial integrity of the of the uk
but
actually what happened at this summit
was that there was
a colossal amount of work
on subjects that had absolutely nothing
to do with brexit
and there has been unity incorporation
all these leaders want president biden's
first g7 to work
but there's division two with these
european leaders
and this one as well united in their
differences with this man
over brexit the president of france
cleared that the issue is a source of
real concern
for our close allies we can't create
disagreements every morning on subject
matters such as this
when we are meeting over three days look
our priorities are to ensure
that our democracies can obtain growth
so to defend our model which after all
has been rendered fragile the host of
this summit learning that global britain
when you're no longer part of the gang
is a lonely place to be tomorrow his
attention returns to these shores
as we find out how long we will have to
wait for covered restrictions to end
bethrick b sky news cornwall